de los estados unidos ante una capacidad
la voluntad la capacidad de hacerlo y lo
hicimos hoy
el éxito extraordinario de esta misión
fue debido a la increíble habilidad
y el coraje del ejército estadounidense
y nuestros diplomáticos y los
profesionales de inteligencia durante
semanas arriesgaron sus vidas para
extraer océanos estadounidenses a los
órganos que nos ayudaron a los
ciudadanos de nuestros aliados y socios
y otros que abordaron países para hacer
del país había un espacio del país
enfrentando presiones de grandes
multitudes que buscaban ser del país y
lo lograron sabiendo
que los chavistas decís que
entre los talibanes estaban acechando
entre las multitudes
y aún así los hombres y mujeres del
ejército estadounidense nuestro grupo de
matiko de los profesiones de
inteligencia hicieron su trabajo y lo
hicieron bien arriesgando sus vidas no
por grandes profesionales sino por el
servicio los demás no en una misión de
guerra sino en una misión de
misericordia
20 personas en servicio resultaron
heridas 13 héroes dieron sus vidas
estaba en la base de dover para recibir
esa transferencia les debemos a ellos a
su familia es una gratitud que jamás
podemos devolver pero que jamás
deberemos olvidar en abril tome la
decisión de acabar esta guerra
como parte de esa decisión establecimos
una fecha de agosto 31 para que las
tropas estadounidenses se retiraron la
función era que más de 300.000
miembros de las fuerzas de seguridad que
en las últimas dos décadas y que
equipamos que serían un fuerte
adversario en su guerra civil en contra
del talibán esa asunción de que el
gobierno ya no podría resistir
por un período de tiempo más allá del
retiro militar resultó no ser precisa
pero
le instruía de nuestros equipos de
seguridad ción al que se preparará para
cualquier eventualidad incluso para esa
y eso fue lo que hicimos así que
estábamos listos cuando las fuerzas de
seguridad canas después de dos décadas
de lucha en nombre de su país y después
de perder a miles de los propios no
resistieron tanto tiempo como
esperábamos estuvimos listos cuando
ellos y el pueblo de afganistán
dieron al gobierno colapsar y al
presidente huir en medio de la
corrupción de la malversación
entregándole el país a sus enemigos al
talibán e
incrementando el riesgo del personal
estadounidense ya nuestros aliados como
resultado
para extraer con seguridad los ciudanos
estadounidenses antes del 31 de agosto
así como el personal de la embajada a
los aliados ya los socios y aquellos
afganos que han trabajado con nosotros y
que lucharon de nuestro lado por 20 años
yo había autorizado
que seis mil tropas estuvieran en kabul
y ayudarán con la seguridad del
aeropuerto como dijo el general mckenzie
esta es la forma en la que la misión fue
diseñada fue diseñada para operar bajo
un estrés severo bajo ataque y eso fue
lo que hicimos desde marzo
hablamos tratamos de hablar 19 meses con
estadounidenses en afganistán
con múltiples advertencias y ofertas de
ayudarlos a evacuar afganistán diría que
incluso a partir de marzo después de
empezar la evacuación hace 17 días
hicimos una evaluación inicial e
identificamos alrededor de 5000
estadounidenses que habían decidido
permanecer en afganistán antes pero
ahora querían abandonar el país
nuestra operación al aire es que terminó
recibiendo
termino extrayendo a más de 5500
estadounidenses extraemos a miles de
ciudadanos y diplomáticos
que estuvieron en afganistán con
nosotros ayudanos atrapar a vilar en
hicimos que nuestro staff ha empleado
alrededor de 2500 personas
evacuaran hicimos que miles de
intérpretes y traductores afganos y
aquellos otros que respaldaron los eeuu
también los extrajimos ahora creemos que
cerca de 1.000 o 2.000 estadounidenses
permanecen afganistán con alguna
intención de abandonar el país la
mayoría de ellos están ahí son
ciudadanos
residentes
que habían decidido inicialmente
quedarse por las raíces familiares que
tienen en afganistán el punto final
que 90% de los estadounidenses en
afganistán que querían irse pudieron
irse
y aquellos estadounidenses que están que
permanecen ahí no hay ninguna fecha
límite
estamos comprometidos con sacarlos si
ellos quieren salir
el secretario de estado blinken está
liderando este esfuerzo continuado este
esfuerzo diplomático para asegurar un
paso seguro para cualquier
estadounidense aliado afgano o algún
extranjero que quiera dejar afganistán
de hecho apenas ayer un
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
pasó una resolución que manda un mensaje
claro mientras la comunidad está y la
comunidad internacional espera que los
talibanes dejen salir evita que respeten
la libertad de viaje la libertad de
salir juntos
con otros 100 países estamos
determinados a asegurarnos que el
talibán mantenga estos compromisos
incluir a los esfuerzos en afganistán
para reabrir el aeropuerto
así como rutas por tierra que permitan
la partida continua de aquellos que
quieran abandonar el país
y también entregar ayuda humanitaria al
pueblo afganistán el talibán ha hecho
compromisos públicos ha transmitido en
televisión en radio en todo organizando
diciendo que hay paso segura para
aquellos que se creen incluyendo
aquellos que trabajaron junto a los
estadounidenses
no les creemos solamente a sus palabras
le creeremos a sus acciones y tenemos la
fuerza para hacer que esos compromisos
sean cumplidos déjenme ser muy claro
abandonar el 31 de agosto
no es una fecha arbitraria esto fue
diseñado para salvar vidas
estadounidenses
mi predecesor el ex presidente firmó un
acuerdo con el talibán para rememorar
tropas estadounidenses hacia el primero
de mayo apenas meses después de mi
inauguración e incluir incluía ningún
tipo de requerimiento para el talibán en
términos de cooperación con el gobierno
afgano
pero si autorizó la liberación de cinco
mil prisioneros en el año pasado
incluyendo algunos de los comandantes
líderes de los talibanes entre ellos
a quien tomó control de organizan
para el momento en que llegue al cargo
el talibán estaba en su mejor posición
militar desde 2001
controlando disputando cerca de la mitad
del país
las administraciones previas el acuerdo
de la administración previa decía que si
nos manteníamos para la fecha límite del
primero de mayo que ya estaba asegurada
el talibán no iba a atacar fuerzas
estadounidenses pero si nos quedábamos
todo esto se iba a acabar entonces se
nos dejó una decisión bastante simple
y seguir el compromiso de la anterior
ministración y dejar afganistán
o decir que no íbamos a abandonar nos
compromete a comprometernos a
comprometer otras decenas de miles de
tropas a volver a la guerra
ésa fue la elección la elección real
entre
abandonar el país o escala de conflicto
yo no iba a extender esta guerra eterna
y no iba a extender una salida eterna la
decisión de acabar las operaciones
militares en el aeropuerto de kabul fue
pro basadas en una recomendación o
minnie unánime por parte de mis socios
civiles y militares secretario de estado
el secretario de defensa el presidente
de los jefes de comando conjunto y todos
los jefes en servicio y los comandantes
en el terreno su recomendación
fue que la manera más seguridad de
asegurar el paso de los estadounidenses
restantes y de otros
en salir del país
no era mantener a 6000 tropas en terreno
en peligro sino sacarlos a través de
medios no militares
en estos 17 días que operamos en kabul
después de que el talibán tomó el poder
empezamos a desarrollar un esfuerzo para
sacar a cada estadounidense o para darle
a cada uno la oportunidad de irse
nuestro departamento de estado estuvo
trabajando 24/7
contactando y conversando en algunos
casos caminando junto a los
estadounidenses en el aeropuerto ave de
nuevo más de
5.500 personas han salido aquellos que
están
y lo hemos hecho y seguiremos en ello
seguiremos trabajando para ayudar a que
más personas salgan del país personas
que están en riesgo y no hemos terminado
estamos bien lejos ahora le pido a todos
los estadounidenses que se unan aún a mí
en oración el nombre de nuestras tropas
los diplomáticos los oficiales de
inteligencia que llevaron a cabo esta
misión de misericordia en kabul
enfrentando un riesgo increíble y
obtenido resultados sin parar
una evacuación aérea que sacó a decenas
de miles de personas a una red de
voluntarios y veteranos que ayudaron
identificar a aquellos que necesitaban
una evacuación guiarlos al aeropuerto y
proveerles
respaldo durante el camino
seguiremos necesitando su ayuda
necesitamos su ayuda y estoy esperando
reunirme con todos ustedes y con todos y
ahora están ofreciendo que ofrecerán
recibir a nuestros aliados afganos a sus
hogares en todo el mundo incluyendo en
eeuu muchas gracias
yo asumo completa responsabilidad por la
decisión ahora algunos dicen que debimos
haber empezado una evacuación masiva
antes
y que eso se pudo haber hecho de una
manera más organizada yo estoy en un
desacuerdo respecto se imagínense que
hubiéramos empezado a evacuar en junio o
en julio
trayendo miles de tropas estadounidenses
y evacuando a más de 120.000 personas en
medio de una guerra civil
hubieran sido hubiera habido todavía una
avalancha en contra del aeropuerto una
ruptura en la confianza el control del
gobierno
y hubiera sido muy difícil y muy
peligroso
el punto final aquí es que no hay
ninguna evacuación del fin de una guerra
de la cual no puede ejercer sin amenazas
sin estrés como nosotros enfrentamos no
hay ninguna posibilidad aquellos que
creen que demostrarnos quedado
indefinidamente
preguntan por qué no seguimos haciendo
lo que estábamos haciendo porque debemos
cambiar
la realidad es que todo había cambiado
ya
mi predecesor había logrado un trato con
el talibán cuando llegue al cargo
enfrentamos una fecha límite mayo 1
la avalancha del talibán estaba llegando
enfrentamos una de dos opciones
seguir con el acuerdo de la anterior
administración
y extenderlo
para darle a más personas el tiempo de
abandonar el país o enviar miles de
tropas más
y hacer que la guerra escalar
y aquellos que pedían una tercera década
de guerra en afganistán les pregunto
cuál es el interés vital para nuestra
nación mi perspectiva solamente teníamos
uno
y
asegurarnos que afganistán no hubiera
sido usada nunca jamás para atacar a
nuestra tierra recuerda porque fuimos
afganistán en la primera vez porque
fuimos atacados por osama bin laden y
por al qaeda el 11 de septiembre de 2001
y estaban basados en afganistán
llevamos justicia a vilar
eso fue hace más de una década y ya
estaba acabado
penosamente le sugiero que se pregunten
esto si fuésemos si fuimos atacados el
11 de septiembre desde yemen hubiéramos
sido atacados desde yemen en vez de
afganistán hubiera mentido alguna guerra
en afganistán
incluso aunque el talibán controlaba a
afganistán en 2001
y yo creo que la respuesta honesta es no
eso es porque no teníamos ningún interés
vital en afganistán más allá de prevenir
un ataque en el suelo estadounidense y
contra nuestros aliados eso sigue siendo
real hoy y si tuvimos éxito en lo que
buscábamos hacer en afganistán hace una
década
y luego nos quedamos por otra década
era momento de acabar esta guerra
este es un nuevo mundo
la amenaza del terror está hecho
metástasis en todo el mundo más allá de
afganistán
enfrentamos amenazas desde al shabab en
somalia
desde al qaeda afiliados al que siria en
la península arábiga
el intento de isis de hacer un califato
en siria y de aquí establecer
afiliados en áfrica y en asia la
obligación fundamental del presidente en
mi opinión es defender y proteger eeuu
no en contra de amenazas de 2001 sino en
contra de las amenazas de 2021 y aquí
adelante
ese es el principio guía detrás en mis
decisiones respecto de afganistán
simplemente no puedo creer que la
seguridad de eeuu sea mejorada por
desplegar continuamente decenas de miles
de tropas de estadounidenses y gastar
miles de millones de dólares al año en
afganistán
pero también sé
que sigue habiendo amenazas
de naturaleza perniciosa y maldad y mala
pero esto ha cambiado se ha expandido
otros países
nuestra estrategia debe cambiar también
mantendremos la lucha en contra del
terrorismo en afganistán y en otros
países
simplemente no necesitamos combatir
a llevar a cabo una guerra en territorio
para hacerlo
se habla de capacidades en crecimiento
significa que podemos atacar a
terroristas sin tener tropas de
estadounidenses en el terreno sin que se
necesiten muchas hemos mostrado esa
capacidad apenas en la última semana
atacamos a isis cada de manera remota
días después de asesinar a 13 de
nuestros hombres en servicios
y docenas de inocentes de afganos
inocentes
y cisca le quiero decir no estamos hemos
acabado con ustedes todavía como
comandante en jefe creo firmemente que
el camino seguro para guiar nuestra
seguridad está del lado
y una estrategia precisa con blancos
claros en contra de los terroristas de
hoy no en contra de los terroristas de
hace dos décadas
eso es lo que está del lado del interés
nacional
aquí hay algo crítico que es necesario
entender el mundo está cambiando
[Música]
estamos en medio de una competición muy
seria con china estamos lidiando con los
desafíos de múltiples frentes por parte
de rusia estamos confundiendo
confrontados por ciberataques por
proliferación nuclear
debemos mostrar la competitiva de
estadounidense enfrentar estos desafíos
y ganar la competencia del siglo 21 y
podemos hacerlo todos luchar este
recurso de contraste el ritmo de
enfrentar las nuevas amenazas del hoy y
seguir seguir estando aquí en el futuro
hay nada que china o rusia preferiría en
tener lo que quieran más en esta
competición que los eeuu estén siendo
detenidos una década más en afganistán
a medida que giramos la página en temas
de
política extranjera que ha guiado a
nuestras las últimas dos décadas tenemos
que aprender de nuestros errores
para mí hay dos muy importantes en
primer lugar debemos establecer misiones
con metas claras y alcanzables no
algunas que jamás alcanzaremos en
segundo lugar
debemos tener un enfoque claro de cuáles
son los intereses nacionales de eeuu de
américa esta decisión alrededor de
organista
no es sólo sobre afganistán
es sobre una era
de grandes operaciones militares y de
reconstruir países rehacer países vimos
misiones de contraterrorismo en
afganistán
haciendo que los ahorristas dejaran de
atacar vimos cómo se transformó en una
contrainsurgencia
en la reconstrucción de un país en el
intento de crear una lista democrática y
cohesionada algo que nunca se había
logrado en muchos siglos de historia
afgana
sabemos de esas ideas
y de esos grandes despliegues si
creíamos que nos iban a hacer mucho más
fuertes que nos iban a ser efectivos
a cualquiera que tenga la idea
equivocada déjeme decirlo claro aquellos
que quisiera que quiere desearle el mal
a eeuu aquellos que están entrando en
prácticas terroristas en contra de
nosotros nuestros aliados sepan estos
estados unidos jamás descansará quien
jamás perdonará que jamás olvidará nos
casaremos hasta el final
y haremos que pague en el último precio
dejen de ser más claro
seguiremos respaldando al pueblo afgano
a través de la diplomacia la influencia
internacional y la ayuda humanitaria
seguiremos insistiendo en la diplomacia
regional para acabar con la violencia y
la inestabilidad
y hablar de los derechos humanos de los
afganos de las mujeres y niñas órganos
así como lo hacemos con las mujeres y
niñas de todo el mundo
he sido claro que los derechos humanos
serán el centro de nuestra política
extranjera pero la manera de hacerlo no
es a través
despliegues militares sin fin sino a
través de la diplomacia las herramientas
económicas y reunir todo el mundo
alrededor de nuestro respaldo compañeros
estadounidenses la guerra en afganistán
se ha acabado
soy el cuarto presidente que ha
enfrentado
el tema de cuándo y cómo terminar esta
guerra
cuál estaba aspirando la presidencia y
su compromiso al pueblo estadounidense
que terminaría esta guerra
hoy ha honrado este compromiso
era un momento de ser honesto con el
pueblo estadounidense de nuevo
ya no teníamos un propósito claro en una
misión abierta y sin fin en afganistán
después de 20 años de guerra en
afganistán me niego a mandar otra
generación de hijos e hijas
estadounidenses a luchar
lucha en una guerra que ya debía haber
acabado hace mucho tiempo después de más
de dos mil dos billones de dólares
gastados en afganistán los costos
investigados por la universidad brown
costó 300 millones de dólares cada día
durante dos décadas en afganistán si
pueblo estadounidense debería escuchar
esto 300 millones de dólares al día por
dos décadas
si usted toma
el número de un
[Música]
millón serían 150 millones de dólares al
día lo que hemos perdido en términos de
consecuencias de oportunidades de diego
a seguir con una guerra que ya no estaba
en servicio de los intereses del pueblo
estadounidense por encima de todo
después de 800 mil estadounidenses que
sirvieron en afganistán
que viajaron por todo el país gente con
coraje gente valiosa después de qué
hubiera más de 20.000 heridos
de la pérdida de más de 200.000
la parte 200.000 vídeos incluso 13 esta
semana yo me niego a abrir otra década
de guerra en afganistán
hemos hemos sido una nación que estado
mucho tiempo en guerra si usted tiene 20
años de edad ahora no ha sabido cómo es
un eeuu en paz
cuando escucho que debimos haber
continuado esta guerra ese esfuerzo de
baja intensidad con bajo riesgo para la
vida de nuestros miembros de seguridad
con bajo costo no creo que mucha gente
realmente lo entienda
lo mucho que le hemos pedido al 1% de
este país que se puso este uniforme que
estaba dispuesto a poner sus vidas en
riesgo en defensa de nuestra nación
de pronto es porque mi hijo fallecido
vos
sirvió en irak por un año antes de eso
bueno
de pronto es porque lo que ya he visto a
lo largo de los años como senador
vicepresidente y presidente viajando
estos países
muchos de estos veteranos y sus familias
han pasado por el infierno
despliegue tras despliegue meses y años
lejos de sus familias
cumpleaños fecha de cumpleaños perdidas
aniversarios perdidos sillas vacías en
las fiestas los problemas financieros
divorcios la pérdida de miembros estrés
postraumático heridas cerebrales
lo vemos estamos viendo las luchas que
muchos tienen cuando vuelven a casa
vemos la presión en sus familias y en
sus cuidadores
vemos la presión en esas familias cuando
no están ahí y la vemos
en la pena y el dolor que cargan los
supervivientes el costo de la guerra
que van a cargar con ellos toda su vida
y incluso más tráfico hemos visto esta
estadística sorprendente que
debería detener a cualquier persona que
la guerra puede ser de baja intensidad
de bajo costo de bajo riesgo
18 veteranos en promedio
que mueren por suicidio cada día en eeuu
no en un sitio distante sino aquí aquí
en eeuu
no hay nada
de baja intensidad de bajo costo o de
bajo riesgo en una guerra es momento de
acabar la guerra en afganistán
a medida que nos acercamos a 20 años de
dolor de guerra de sacrificios el
momento de mirar hacia el futuro no
hacia el pasado
al futuro un futuro que es más seguro un
futuro
que ofrece más tranquilidad o futuro que
honra a aquellos que sirven
aquellos que dieron lo que el presidente
lincoln llamó la última medida de
devoción
doy mi palabra con todo mi corazón
creo
qué es la decisión correcta una decisión
sabia
y la mejor decisión para eeuu
muchas gracias y que dios los bendiga a
todos y que dios proteja protejan esas
tropas